say that
o hi I'm Patrick Del perio and I'm a
Lector of Cherokee language in the
department of linguistics now if I want
to add some more to it or more emphasis
I'd say the big things that's hard for
people to get is the tone and the Rhythm
to wait to the one word that comes to
mind is Andi the first word is baby
which
isy the second word isy which is small
so you can hear that that slight change
or that slight tone even the length of
the of the syllable changes the meaning
so if you say CL no I've often heard
other language Learners say that
learning the language changes their
worldview I hope to see that from my
students I hope that Heritage language
Learners feel more connected to their
Heritage their ancestry their
identity my late Mentor Durban feeling
said that he envisioned a Cherokee
Renaissance and I hope that this is a
part of
[Music]
that